what I've been wondering is you know if
you've got a lot of pictures of horses
and you really want to turn them into a
lot of pictures of zebras how are you
gonna do that right marker pen yeah
marker pen for some life there that is
quicker today we're going to talk about
cycle gap which is a really interesting
innovation in generative adversarial
networks now rob has already covered
this in one of his videos what a gun is
and what it's used for
typically generating images of interest
pictures of trees pictures of people
pictures of buildings you know you can
train ganas to do these kind of things
what's interesting about ganz he you
actually have two networks you have one
their work that's learning to generate
images and you have a second network
that's learning to try and tell the
difference between the generated ones
and some example real images and by
training the both together you force the
generator to produce more realistic
looking images there's another domain
that Ganz are useful right which is not
generating an image from scratch it's
turning an image from one domain into
another so for example you might take a
photo to try and make you look like a
painting or you might take a
black-and-white photo and try and make
it a colored photo or something like
this there are lots of ways to do this
kind of style transfer but gans are one
of the ways you could do it it's gonna
be slightly different to what what was
talking about because in this case we
have an image going in not just noise
and we have an image coming out so one
way you could train this is just with a
standard kind of encoder decoder Network
like we've talked about before so you
might have an image let's say here so
this is a photograph and you have a kind
of encoder decoder networks like this
that we're gonna call our generator and
then it outputs another image these
aren't typically too big but they
usually do filter the network down and
back up again and then we have I know an
artist impression or something like that
of the picture now one way we could
train this is to get a bunch of
paintings and a bunch of photos of where
those paintings were sort of captured
font right or Commission a bunch of
artists to go out and paint the load of
stuff that we have the photograph for
and then we've got this supervised
training data that we could use we could
just put in pairs of photo what it's
meant to look like in painting form and
then
even train a net weather hopefully we'll
map one to the other and the idea I
guess is that you then put in a new
photo but it's never seen and it does a
nice job of painting it right that's the
hope so this is like a kind of basic
level of training up a network to
produce some kind of style transfer but
the problem is that it's a bit of a pain
to have to get these pairs of data right
so a lot of the time the data isn't
paired a lot of time we have a lot of
pictures of paintings we have a lot of
pictures of photos but it all look
completely different places so producing
a mapping between one and the other is a
little bit more difficult what a gam
does is has a discriminator here so this
is going to be a discriminator and this
is is it a real or fake image the bet of
a discriminator gets at detecting the
fake paintings the better mix generators
will have to get converting photos to
paintings right that would be the idea
and this works pretty well why and it
works well for generating photos and
third foot changing photos into other
domains but gans have a lot of problems
with training that make them quite
difficult to use in practice one of them
is something called mode collapse
imagine that we are trying to produce
again now that takes a picture horse and
converts it into a picture of a zebra so
what's happening is we put in a random
picture of a horse and then the
discriminators is it a real zebra or
fakes everywhere and if it's determined
to be a fake this generators gonna have
to get better at changing that horse
into a zebra
horses into zebras is a kind of
arbitrary problem that you might wonder
what why we do in that well for fun
mostly but also because actually it's
just a textual check text will change
the shape of a zebra is approximately
the same as a shape of a horse which
makes this problem slightly easier right
we're talking about adding stripes we're
not talking about totally changing the
shape of the object the problem is that
let's imagine that the generators have
realized for discriminator how in
terminator worked and just said okay i'm
going to produce this exact same picture
a zebra this is gonna look bad by the
way so this is my picture of a zebra how
did I am good is it right again again
again would have been better an
untrained can work I've been better now
so let's suppose the generator
generate this same picture every time
any picture of a horse cause it just
generates that picture it's a simple you
asked was ever here's who's ever it's
the only one you're getting man this is
something called mode collapse the idea
is that the generator has now completely
failed to produce interesting pictures
just producing the same picture every
time imagine we wanted a generator that
produce digits like six five four three
and this was determining whether they
were real did you or not well if you
just produce six every time it's problem
is so much easier and we discriminate it
can't complain about that because they
are technically digits this is the exact
same problem so cycle Gann is
essentially a two gun system that deals
with this very problem
so how does it do it well what we have
is we have two guns alright because if
one is good then two better and what we
try to do is we're trying to make sure
that not only are we taking our image
and turning into something that looks
good and it's in it's indistinguishable
from a real one but also that we can
then go back again to prove that we
haven't just generated the same license
image it's got nothing to do with the
input right so this is our input we have
a generator a generator Network G so
this is G which is going to generate a
picture of a let's say as of a zebra
then we have another network F alright
which is taking pictures of zebras and
turning them back into pictures of
horses so there's two guns and there's
going to be two discriminators right
this is a scream later here saying is
this a real picture of a zebra question
mark to a discriminator and when as a
discriminator here saying is this a real
picture of a horse so there's a lot of
loss functions being applied here
what's a loss function a loss function
is a function we use to calculate how
wrong or right a particular network is
so in this case the loss function is you
were supposed to say this was a real
image and you said it was a fake image
so your arrow is that is that much right
without going to any numbers that's
basically what it does right but this is
how we train these things right you
calculate a loss just say look you were
supposed to say this was a fake zebra
but actually you
the wheels Emperor so next time change
your weight so that you say it was a
feint ever that's what the loss function
is for so a horse comes in the G
generator turns it into a zebra
theoretically right this goes into the F
function it turns it back into a horse
and then we have a final loss which is
what is the difference between this
horse here and this horse here
because if we can't recreate the exact
same image then we just produce a
different picture whereas everywhere but
it's that's cheating my for this to work
we have to convert this horse into a
zebra not just produce a picture of his
ever you see what I mean right the same
with something like star transfer to a
Monet painting right we take a
photograph we turn it into a Monet
painting it looks great but if we can't
turn it back then what you've done is
just draw a male painting for me it's
got nothing to do with the input so in
some sense this G and F function are
inverses of one another one does of a
function and the other one undoes the
function what's interesting about cycle
gain apart from the fact this kind of a
loop here is they have this loss that
also measures a distance between this
image and this image so not only ensure
that these are both producing
realistic-looking inputs and outputs but
that these two at the end of the same
and you can do it both ways you can go
horse to zebra to horse and measure this
distance here and to make sure they're
same and you can go zebra to horse as
ever
and make sure this distance is the same
right so you can work in both ways you
can put F first or G first so this is
exactly how you train it you take a
number of images of horses and a number
of images of zippers and then you train
it just like again you say well here's a
horse image go in was it a real image or
not right and sometimes you give the
discriminative real images sometimes you
give it fake images and it tries to get
better with that you don't put it
through after to toe it back into a
horse back discrimination is also
working to make sure this F function is
better and then you make sure these two
are the same as well one way of looking
at this is that you're trying to
separate out what the content of images
and what a style of images I'm the
content should be the same alright the
content of the horse image and the zebra
image should be the same because if it's
not you won't be able retrieve one from
the other
the style is you know aspect
how it looks my is it a painting is it a
zebras at horse these are things that we
can apply later kind of to the base
image that makes sense and this can be
applied to a whole array of different
problems like this kids in medical
imaging right we're looking at it in
plant imaging it's used for style
transfer so in the paper alone there was
about 10 different examples of things
you can do you can Kate you can take
pencil drawings and turn them into into
men doings of an object so like you know
a boy of a shoe - an actual picture of a
shoe you can go from photos to Monet
paintings to Van Gogh paintings you can
go from horses to zebras apples to
oranges and the list goes on right and
if you have a look online you'll see all
kinds of weird wonderful things that
people are using this cycle can and
variants of it too to do is a resolution
good no it's okay right the the
resolutions are get so this kind of size
of training data we're talking about 30
centimeters is in the hundreds of pixels
squared so 2 to 500 pixels squared
usually training them takes all the
memory once they're trained you can put
through so if what we say inference time
you can put through bigger images and
there were ways you could train it so
that it will work on bigger images when
it actually gets to applying it right
but the images I've been testing on a
smaller 512 by 512 something like that
we're not converting for Herod is yet
there are there is work that maybe we'll
talk about overtime lifestyle gang which
does try and produce higher resolution
output what you'll find I think if you
watch a video of a cycle gun being
applied to every frame of an image it's
gonna be little bit noisy is you're
gonna have to take steps it tries to
move that out there's a few videos of
like parts of 2001 a Space Odyssey as a
Picasso painting where every frame is a
Picasso painting it's quite something to
look at right but there's a bit of noise
because you know the input changes even
slightly some is going to change on the
output right and so it sort of flickers
to get it to get it to be smooth you're
gonna have to do some kind of extra
processing so I've come on this right
you can you can download the code online
we'll put a link in the description you
can download it as long as you've got
all graphics card you can start putting
random pictures of horses in turn them
into random pictures of zebras and feel
bit pleased of yourself these kind of
Gans are being used for all kinds of
things that you see like a super
resolution for example way taking a very
low resolution image and you want to
sort of blow it up so we can see a lot
of fine detail you know that's sort of
CSI it harms in arts it zoom in on that
I have some concerns about this because
one thing to remember is that these are
trained to look nice they're not trained
to be an accurate representation of the
ground truth specifically right there's
no if you take a blurry image and you
know I'm saying this to cover my own
back more anything else if you take a
blurry image and you zoom it up and it
looks like me that's probably a
coincidence you can't trust that it was
actually me maybe more but it makes you
know but my point is like you're not
gonna be a loser in a court of law
because it could be argued that it just
created an interesting looking face it's
not created the actual face from these
few pixels this it's gonna be a while
before we're looking at networks that
can actually work out what truly someone
look like if you look at the input and
output of this cycle can for example
you'll see that it'll take a horse and
turn into a zebra and when it turns it
back the images are close but they're
not the same often the grant is a little
bit muted I think probably because
there's ever tend to be on dryer grass
I'm sort of the plains and stuff right
so it changes the rest of the image as
well to deal with this so these
interesting things there does so
super-resolution it's one thing that's
used for medical imaging converting from
one domain of medical image like an MRI
to a CT scan right I'm quite worried I
wouldn't use case for that is but you
know there's a lot these sort of things
can be done
the recent Samson video where they had
people's faces and things like deep
fakes right which are I would just say
morally questionable but these are all
things generated using these Joseph's
adversarial networks you're taking
inputs which are you know noise or other
images or pose estimations if you're
trying to make a face do and when it's
generating an image what looks like that
thing so there's lots of ways of
controlling what different bits of this
do to get an output that you want
encryption and specifically kind of
modern encryption and how it works
now Before we jump straight into
something like the Advanced Encryption
standard I wanted to talk about SP
networks or substitution permutation
networks because they are the basis for
a lot of modern cryptography not all of
it but a lot of symmetrical